i wanna i wanna i wanna pull up this uh
tweet because it's friday's we're gonna
have some fun i have this tweet uh from
shu on head
everybody i i'm i'm sure you know she
wanna wait wait wait this this this
tweet it could potentially be considered
violence now tim are we good to show
this yeah this it actually is very
dangerous uh alexandria ocasio-cortez
called for violence but we're reporting
on her call for violence and we are
denouncing and we are absolutely
denouncing no no
for the sake of
clarity aoc in a video said that people
should be you know i'm not going to say
it no aoc was asking people to send
emails and phones you're going to do it
i know you got to be yeah because
youtube is crazy right aoc speaking on
the video was like everybody call your
reps call their offices send them
messages and post cards but she didn't
quite say there is a phrase that is
i'm going to play it
their phone line i'm going to play what
you said you guys ready audio let me i
always got i always gotta fix the audio
because we were we were playing
something here we go you ready you ready
and we need to be really blowing up our
elected officials offices
says loud and clear queen
it's a funny thing
is lefty she's like left a libertarian
and so many lefties got really mad that
she posted this why they were like it's
out of context obviously well duh that's
a joke
you know what aoc means aoc is saying
call your local reps standing back and
standing by standing back and standing
by ted kozinski come on here's why i
bring this up
not in any way to drag aoc i mean
there's a lot of things to criticize her
for i i just we the video the video clip
from this show
when she went on colbert and just made
up stuff we called aoc we called like
what was it aoc paul's chad move yes
live chat by blatantly lying on tv lying
on live sheamus was right he was like
do you know what happened with this no i
didn't see this aoc went on colbert and
he was like what should the president do
in response to row and she goes
well we're informed by history you know
uh looked at the civil war
the confederacy had taken over the
supreme court and were ruling in ways
that was impeding abraham lincoln like
dred scott that's that ruled black
people couldn't be citizens so what did
abraham lincoln do he signed the
emancipation proclamation and when i
watched that happen i was like banging
my head on the table because it's just
like a hodgepodge
it's actually kind of a wrong word it's
like it's actually kind of a chat move
yes it's kind of chad it's it's sort of
like
it it reminds me of like the you know
the sort of like like the secret
president theory and some of the
different things
right if you don't like your own version
like if you don't like reality it's not
your life your liking you just make up
your own oh yeah but but but with this
one it was kind of just like i'm
imagining a dude sitting back and being
like abraham lincoln his cousin winston
churchill oh did you know that yeah
people don't know this and uh john
wilkes booth maybe uh third cousins it's
two they don't know maybe
three-year letterman on twitter so let
me just for the sake of just for the
sake of uh breaking this down because i
have to do it
too i know i know you guys may have seen
this segment we did on it but i want to
advan i want to talk about media that's
what we're talking about here with the
story but uh just to clarify
uh the confederacy did not take over the
supreme court maybe she means they were
more sympathetic to the self fine dred
scott was four years before abraham
lincoln became president so no the
supreme court was not impeding him the
confederacy had already seceded before
abraham lincoln was even president the
emancipation proclamation was signed two
years after he became president six
years after dred scott and in no way had
anything to do with dred scott by the
way in the middle of the war right right
right and it wasn't until the end of the
war and the 14th and 15th amendment that
citizenship was granted to slaves so she
she just made everything up but anyway i
digress aoc i need to brush up on your
dune teeth history seriously i agree i
am not bringing up this clip of her
saying you know blowing up offices or
whatever to drag her i'm doing to make a
point about the media right because this
is what they do the fact that aoc said
it and we know the intent of what she
said
modern media doesn't give that benefit
to anyone associated with the right no
at all ever
donald trump could come out and be like
he'll be like did you see this video of
aoc saying blowing up offices now we
know she mentions we know what she meant
and then they'll say donald trump pushes
idea that you should
you know blow up offices or something
like that
and then they've done this to me where
they were like there are these things go
around you and i are both on these
things where they claim that we are
pushing election election misinformation
stuff
what do we do
there's a bunch of these studies where
it's like you know tim
oh the studies right right right they
never they never quite explained what it
is that you said they just said no they
just decide that you said them and then
they they put you on the list
here's what they do here's what they do
i'll give you an example shane
tell me
that uh
the sky is not green
sky is not green oh shane cashman pushes
idea about sky actually being green
promoting the theory that sky is
potentially green that's right it's true
by bringing it up and saying anything
about it you've pushed and you say like
you promote can you say shane cashman
quote the sky is dot dot dot green they
do that
that's the point about the word out i
mean come on that's illusionists of the
editing world that's the point about
what aoc said
it's technically a functional way to
question someone you guys ready for this
one what is decepticon we got another
clip she won the head says
she looks absolutely here she looks
upset all right you need to listen to
this you ready
supremacy is a fact
it's not just a fact
you look at
fbi statistics
oh no
no white supremacy is uh okay
yeah that's that's what they show hold
on hold on
that's that's that's it
i got a legitimate question jamie pull
off the fbi statistics yeah in what
actual context is she saying these
things because um why is she telling
people to pull up the fbi stats that's
interesting i said i think it's no there
actually is there is an fbi
uh report that will come out talk and
talking about um
white identity extremists and or racial
identity extremists or whatever the
latest term is for it and they will
find all these things like somebody
committed suicide but then they'll
consider that a homicide or you know
something is tangentially involved and
they will call it a a white terrorist
attack and they will use this to create
this like hugely inflated number out
there which is coming out from the fbi
saying that um that this is the greatest
threat to america today let me let me
write this down
there ben and jerry's pushed this racist
idea uh
the issue is
the left and the right will cite the
same stat in the fbi to make the
opposite claims right
the stat posted by ben jerry's
that
you know the black population is 13 of
the united states yet incarceration
rates among the black population is way
higher which is quite literally the
exact same argument made by white
supremacists so when aoc comes out and
says white supremacy is is a fact
it sounds like out of context she's
saying it is real like it it is it is a
true thing like like she's promoting she
believes they're right right right
and then when she mentions fbi stats
what she said
could could be slightly altered and come
right out of the mouth of a white
supremacist oh yeah you're right
it's it's it's it's all it's the exact
argument because they project everything
well because the the woke editorial left
the critical race theorists are outright
right racist so they look at everything
and they're like that's the only
explanation and they're making the same
argument the difference is who they
think is the racist person aoc's
argument is oh this proves the police
are racist because these people
shouldn't be in jail whereas white
supremacists are like it proves bad
things about black people when in
reality they're looking at the same stat
asserting some racialized ideology and
just making everything worse for
everybody
thanks aoc but there's also there's also
an element of what um michael anton at
claremont has has written about this and
he calls it the celebration parallax
where he says
if the
if the left cites something
then we have to say oh it's happening
and it's and it's good and it's
wonderful that this is happening but if
the right identifies the same uh
pattern or trend in society it's it's a
conspiracy and it's wrong and it's
probably racist to even talk about it
right so you and you can say this about
a the great reset is a great example of
this right you know where you can where
where they'll come out and say or even
with the the thing that was uh going out
today the liberal world order if you
went on twitter today and typed in
liberal world order you would think oh
it's going to play that clip of brian
deese who is the white house economic
advisor when they ask him the question
you know why are americans paying f 4.85
uh cents a gallon going into you know
fourth of july weekend he says well it's
for you know i'm paraphrasing
we have to protect the liberal award
order and and people are said oh well at
least he's honest right you know um guy
but comes from blackrock by the way and
if you went to twitter
and searched that uh earlier today i
don't know if it's still there and so if
you if you search it today right now
it's still there it's all up yeah that
if you search it there was a fact check
that was the first thing that you saw
and it said fact check
comments today about liberal world order
are not the same as the conspiracy
theory that a new world order is being
instituted by
the united states government that is not
up anymore now it's it goes right to the
new york post article new york post
probably just helped to dispense with it
and your stuff actually it was there at
my stomach tweeted the video yeah right
wow you know and there was a fact
because before we can even let you
engage with the content that was again
stated by
the white house economic advisor
regarding why your gas prices are so
high right
they had to correctly
frame it for you like i left this meme
before you can even interact with the
actual thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there